a minute scattered air-fluid ooh money
the rule is simple if you laugh you will
lose and Otero may do an inter flora
Manon
oh do flora do okay Edna that Pesce okay
okay let's do this
have you accepted the challenge very
well let's see if you can beat this
challenge
haters higher intense gratit how did you
go how did it go for you so far so good
so far so good everybody what is it
general my lord the fleet has moved out
of light speed comm scan has detected an
energy field
no it's one of these
goddammit
goddammit well done editing that as
classic Simplot simple editing can
really make such a huge difference well
done whoever did that one day you're
probably not watching but I'm just
saying well done because I am such a hey
hey bazinga if you get paid two million
dollars for doing nothing then yes you
are a genius I will go as far as say
that listen to this [ __ ] oh my god
I become edit that out Jesus Christ look
at the look of intensity are - the
question is can seven get inside my anus
- is going to be careful of a liver kick
this is not where - wants to be my anus
is most comfortable on the ground not a
good place for - to be - Lisa loosen up
a little here we know Pat that - can
take a pounding in combat needs you
thing to say - katiyal electro daddy -
wants to take him there to get into the
deep water so far so good for -
semmen did say yesterday he has enormous
respect for - - didn't quite have the
time on the ground engagement jab - my
innocence movement has been so good here
such a 12 year old god damn it what's
his name
my I ain't why would that be his name my
I understand like ma I but is his last
name actually eNOS
maybe I anis like a nice my unease you
have [ __ ] parents no wonder you get
into boxing or UFC fighting whatever
it's called I don't know all I know is I
would be able to beat them up all of
them with these guns baby Kenan let's
watch some anime all right well we got
oh love is like a [ __ ] tail ana main
really knows how to do romance properly
like I never seen before I think I've
seen that one actually it's a Christian
that's so creepy weirdos was that
Christian can someone confirm my guide
well I definitely lost
don't ruin Bolognese for me please why
would you did come on man come on man
that's not cool
you said a deal man didn't assign
nothing no none I see that video of you
that was yesterday is that I see you in
there Alex what label is Linda records
isn't yes rough Hey well just between me
you in a year yeah there's no reason
it's the same way you said that you
don't say Malay no it does not
well island is ioe and in London England
where the ting goes it's funny should
look it up that's no that's for another
whole episode the heck is this
me
that's right
ah
never give up this is the New Year's to
do it guy Japanese Shia LaBeouf never
give up never give up let me see if I
can do it what are you doing
never give up semi-coma do you know how
[ __ ] annoying it is can people just
leave me alone all the time
it's rules dr. steve brule I've seen
this one and you see rule will focus on
genders some people our boys wouldn't
want to be girls some girls wanna be
boys just be happy with your vagina
already don't have to make it new one
and if you got a pennis just keep an eye
on it he'll cut it off
you got it already
yes these editing are so good that's
like five different clips okay for sugar
yeah
skip that dough for low ready that's
what that means okay
some of them might you just don't
understand I don't understand what you
want from me let's face it the new
YouTube sucks it's just not as good as
what it used to be yes the unregistered
hybrid came to end
so true Oh sucks
now you have to censure we're [ __ ] a
swear word to be honest yes YouTube does
suck in the ad pocalypse hit me pretty
hard it's terrible I don't know what to
do with myself I'm gonna have to open a
patreon it's getting real desperate why
would you like King character from
splatoon like what kind of pathetic life
is that
wait a minute oh no no no no no a
Spectre I cannot have this video in the
video because YouTube will then say no
not money for you Felix and I'm like but
it's just an edgy joke about suicide
nothing wrong with sirs no we're gonna
move on to the next video now Scott the
new flora dude don't forget yeah this
[ __ ] clip from Star Wars why was that
in the film oh my god and it's green
everyone is like it's a reference to the
first Star Wars where he has blue milk
well then why the hell is a green milk
and why does he drink it it's not funny
it's gross like if you're a walrus if
you wanna milk a walrus fine milk a
walrus you know first of all it not to
be all vegan old preaching [ __ ] but milk
is disgusting it's repulsive
you're drinking titty milk okay maybe
this is like a commentary on the fact
that how disgusting that is all the
hormones and basic for coughs to grow
strong you're drinking that [ __ ] no
wonder you're growing man boobs like a
[ __ ] weirdo fine okay fine you know
what milk is fine okay let's just put
that on the radar cuz I don't care but
you have a creature that sits up like a
human being it sits up like this you
don't see my crotch region now but just
imagine that there's four titties here
and someone just sticks a can there and
it's just disgusting is repulsive it's
double layers there's too many layers
and the reference thing that doesn't
work have you last got that yet or not
great people keep posting this one look
at this guy's dank dot web
oh my god it was solved instead of sugar
because if you pour sugar on yourself
it doesn't hurt but salt really hurts
that is so dank oh my god that is
hilarious oh my god it was salt I mix up
the salt and the sugar oh my how could
anyone do that oh my god
why am i criticizing jokes and the
unfunniest youtuber on this website
let's talk about your options
okay Cal focus like I'm listening to
what you're saying but I only hear what
I want to that's just called being a
woman Oh
thug life he's not respecting the women
all right okay that's an outdated meme
as well everything is just not funny
nothing is funny it well that was funny
clearly so stupid chicken yeah
well that was amazing thank you thank
you for that one that was great thank
you uh okay we finished the whole thread
fantastic that's two threads of garbage
oh boy we'll move in people are naming
Star Wars even the movies now oh yeah
imagine if that would happen instead of
layer just going I'm gonna sleep now for
two hours and then I'll be fine
ah damn it was just getting good
damn it just love dancing huh hey that's
what get up da da furloughed I do -
thank you very much for watching another
one if you watch the first version of
this video congratulations you watched
the fam the leaves family-friendly
version if you watch version 7 then I'm
sorry you probably been laugh at all
humor it's not advertised about what are
you thinking
you stupid thank you for leaving a like
let's get this one to trending I'm your
host PewDiePie and I'll see you guys
next time